We worked with Sam when he started
OpenAI and Sam was like XYZ is gonna
happen. Anyone that was like, "Okay,
Sam, like I'll follow you did great."
>> Yeah.
>> And 98% of people were like, "No, no,
no, no, no." That's crazy. And so
there's there's often super talented
people that you know are talented that
people still choose to ignore.
>> This is [music] Dalton plus Michael and
today we're going to talk about how to
have a successful career in tech. So we
know there are a lot of people who watch
your videos. not all of them doing
startups. And we know a lot of the
startup founders, well, this might be
news to you. So, a lot of the startup
founders, their startups might not work
out and they might get jobs in tech. And
so, this video is for you. And let's be
clear, most people think about a
successful care is how do we make money?
>> Yes. And deep fulfillment, but also
money.
>> Yes. So, to paraphrase, how to get rich.
[laughter]
is that if we were paraphrasing, you
should [laughter]
>> step one um what it's like to live and
work in Silicon Valley for as long as I
have, it's been like 30 years,
>> is you see waves and cycles, but one
underlying truth is that there are
pockets of talent.
>> Yes.
>> Where the smartest people are at any one
time.
>> Yes,
>> you can kind of figure out where they
are. We'll talk about how in a second.
And talent is mobile.
>> And so you'll see the talent move from
company to company as the industry
changes as new technologies come out.
Yes.
>> To start with, just give you some
examples. You know, when I was in
undergrad um at Stanford in like the
late 2000s, Google was the hot new
startup that was recruiting on campus
and a lot of my professors had
affiliations with Google. And so I knew
that Google was a really cool like it
was it was aware to me as an undergrad
>> that something was happening there.
Yeah. And that really smart people
worked there
>> really early.
>> Yes.
>> PreIPO. Pre D. Yes.
>> Definitely preipo. Right. And like you
know prior generation Sun Microsystems
like there were other sorry to even use
the term but
>> cracked engineers like where all the
cracked engineers work? You can kind of
ask around and people would tell you. I
think from my story,
I thought Yale was going to be this deep
talent pocket. Certainly a lot of smart
people, but like probably not as
differentiated as I thought when I was
in high school. And then for me, it was
about moving geographically. It was
about um finding Justin Khan and Emtt
Shear who actually were talented and
seeing how they first went to Y
Cominator a pocket of talent and then
they went to Silicon Valley a pocket of
talent and it was interesting because I
had a survey of my friends and I can't
say that this was like a plan but it's
like interesting that I followed these
two people [laughter]
and it worked out. It worked out, but it
worked out. And these two people, I
don't know who they were following, but
they got the [__] out of do like, right?
Like, it was like they had a nose that
New Haven, Connecticut or New York or
Cambridge was not where the pocket was
developing. They had a nose they had to
be in the valley.
>> I'll give you a couple other anecdotes
just from even college.
>> I remember I was friends with this guy
named Bob.
>> Okay.
>> Bob was a good programmer. Yeah.
>> Um, and he dated this girl that lived in
my dorm. And so he was always in my
dorm. Yep. And so I talked to Bob
constantly like I just like I always
would see Bob and I remember Bob telling
me
>> that he got an internship when he was
like a sophomore or junior at this tiny
startup in Palo Alto called PayPal.
>> Mhm.
>> And I was really curious and he told me
all about how actually the job was all
about defending against the Russian mob.
>> Like apparently PayPal was just getting
like destroyed by organized crime. And
he was like, "Yeah, so we're building
all this like hardcore technology to
fight like the Russian mob."
>> Yes. Money laundering. To fight my
money.
>> So basically, I love talking to him
about his weird internship at this tiny
startup called PayPal.
>> Yes.
>> And he was an elite engineer and he was
saying, "Oh, all the other people that
work here are really good."
>> Then Bob went to Palunteer because it
was the same people. Then Bob after like
eight years at Palunteer went to OpenAI.
N that
>> and most recently Bob was the chief
scientist of OpenAI.
[laughter] I think he created thinking
models and I that's my friend from the
dorms right there.
>> There it is.
>> Um and now he has a new startup. He's
cool. Yeah. But basically I watched his
career
>> like if you just looked at where Bob
went
>> that was a deep talent pool.
>> There's it's there's signal in that
folks to the extent you know Bob's
>> or friend of friends pay attention to
where they go.
>> Yes. and try to go to those same places
as early as possible.
>> Well, I love the point about paying
attention where where they go,
you actually have to build relationships
like you got to know this Bob. I talked
to this person who wants to start a
company and they said to me in college
the software engineers weren't cool.
They weren't the people you should get
to know. It wasn't obvious. And so this
person was like, I never made friends
with them. And so it's like that talent
pool was there. In hindsight, it was
obvious that you should have followed
them, but you never got to know them
well enough to know that that was
actually interesting talent pool. See,
kind of not only have to be around
talent, you have to engage with those
people and become friends with them.
>> Yes.
>> Which is I think like hilariously like
>> I think for me it's like those are the
people who are fun to be friends with.
>> Yes.
>> But those are often not the coolest
kids.
>> Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> Um indeed I I'm going to I'm not going
to add anything to that. Yeah, I'll let
that stand. Yes. Um their value acrru
over time perhaps.
>> And and again to me the the lesson is
that you don't have to know everything.
You don't need even be the smart person
to have a great career in tech,
>> but you need to know who the smart
people are.
>> Yes.
>> And listen to what they say carefully.
It's like the hunter follows the dog and
the dog's on the scent.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> I mean, it's like, you know, we we
worked with Sam when he started OpenAI
and Sam was like XYZ is going to happen.
Anyone that was like, "Okay, Sam, like
I'll follow you did great."
>> Yeah.
>> And 98% of people were like, "No, no,
no, no, no, no."
>> And so there's there's often super
talented people that you know are
talented that people still choose to
ignore. Well, let's talk about one of
the reasons why people choose to ignore
this because I hear this all the time
when I when I see some when I walk talk
to a YC finder who's considering working
at a company or an engineer is
considering working at a company. The
things that they talk about like
frustrate me to no end because it's like
look you're working a technology company
fundamentally a big part of your
conversation is going to be stock and a
big part of you eventually getting rich
is that stock being worth something. So,
like my first thought is like, what is
your thesis on why that stock would be
worth something? That is like the last
thing they talk about. They're like,
"Well, here's the people that
interviewed me and like the interview
process or the recruiter I talked to and
what the recruiter said, which is like,
what does that matter?" Um, here's like
the benefits, which is like this is not
what the game, this is not how to win by
maximizing your benefits. They say stuff
like, "Well, this is the job I'm going
to like." Oh, I'm like this job would be
more interesting versus that job. And
it's like if you're a technology
company, you can move around. Your jobs
change. Weird geographic stuff like oh I
want to be close to my friends and they
all went to New York so I want to go to
New York.
>> And it's like I mean if you don't want
to win then then fine [laughter]
do whatever you want. Like
>> if you want to win there might be some
trade-offs. And and the mentality I
always give people is like look like
think about how hard investors work to
figure out which companies to invest in
and they get to hedge.
>> Yeah.
>> You don't get to hedge your time. You
can only work with one company at a
time. Perhaps in addition to those kind
of lifestyle things, you should be
asking yourself the question, what is
your thesis on why this stock might be
worth more money? And the questions that
come out, I think, are so much more
interesting.
>> Yep. you know, like are people using the
product?
To your point about talent, am I
ridiculously impressed with the
engineers they have talking to me? Is
the revenue growing?
>> Y and like I'll see people with like
these weird things. It's like, oh,
here's their valuation and it's like
fine, but like can you underwrite that
valuation? Do you actually understand
what's going on in the business? The
other thing that's so funny is that good
founders want to share this information.
Oh, we've got great customer retention.
Of course, you want to tell people that
bad founders when you start asking these
questions, they're going to be like
this. Oh, that's private or you know,
weird [__] you know, and you're like,
oh, really? Like the selling point, the
what otherwise would be a selling point
is private.
>> That's a hit.
>> Yeah. The way I'd summarize what you're
saying is you got to think like an
investor and are you long or short? Yes.
The place. And maybe one other nuance
here, I don't know if we have the
absolute answer here, but people that
are great at having a career in tech
know when to leave.
>> Yes.
>> There's a lot of folks that stay too
long.
>> Yes.
>> And we're not saying leave after 9
months or, you know, we're not saying be
a short-term. That's bad. But like like
our Bob example,
>> Bob changed jobs a small number of
times, but they were all pretty good.
And there's a lot of people that went
from Google to Facebook to Open AI.
>> Yeah.
>> They didn't stay in any one place that
long. And so job hopping bad, but
choosing to move on after what, 3 to 5
years, something like that. Yeah. Not
the worst idea sometimes.
>> Well, and and I don't even think it has
to be time based, right? If you want to
be in deep density pockets and every day
you're re-underwriting, there's awesome
people I get to work with. I think
there's a way to work at Google for 25
years and be in deep density pockets.
>> Apple Apple's such a weird beast. Yeah.
>> Everyone there's a lifer. Like Apple's
just such a strange culture where I
don't think people I think you just go
there and you stay at Apple forever.
>> It is rare that you get to build the
phone that most of the like people use,
right? Like it's like it's like how how
often do you get to do that? And it's
rare that that consumer product is so
consistently the best product for
>> Yep. a decade. So I'll say like whether
you're jumping around between companies,
between teams and this is applies to
startups. It applies to big companies
too. Like I had a friend who just moved
from Facebook over to Google because
Google's AI products are doing really
well and they were able to get a job
inside of Google Brain and it's like yep
that's very interesting. So this doesn't
require even touching into the software
I mean into the startup pool but um it
does also sometimes require you to
sacrifice that salary and I think maybe
that's what I want to end on is that
like you get rich with the equity.
Yes, that's where you're getting.
>> Yes. The problem people have is they
have vanity
and titles and number of reports
>> and all this crap. You get caught up of
like leveling up your character like I
got promoted to L62 and like you know
>> Yes. in the company that's failing.
>> Yeah. You you basically start optimizing
for these weird local inside baseball
things.
>> Yes.
>> And that's a trap I guess is what we're
trying to super big trap. If you have to
consistently underwrite your stock every
year and you have to consistently ask
yourself, "What's my thesis why this
stock will be worth four, five, 10, 100
times more?" You're going to get a clear
view. All right. All right. Thanks,
Michael. Cheers.